big day for your brother press
conference the fight is happening in a
few weeks but this is also kind of a big
deal for you yeah because you lost to
ksi so what have you told your brother
what kind of advice have you given him
and how are you feeling today so I feel
great like typically I'm like pretty in
in a good mood today today especially
because I can kind of just sit back and
watch the show
versus be the show I was telling my
friends like I'm so used to you know
being the guy that has to talk the press
conference now I can just sit back and
be like yeah that's my brother
you're taking off yes exactly it's my
favorite and then yeah as far as advice
I gave him excuse me getting over
influenza everyone's got the flu no no
influenza like I'm dying I'm dying but
I'm good it's very simple Jake needs to
avenge me like I I uh you know in many
ways I let I let the fanbase down I let
our family down and especially Jay cuz
he was in training camp with me he was
working just as hard as I was and it's
up to him to uh put some respect back on
on the Paul family name do you feel like
he has that added pressure on him and
how do you sort of help alleviate that
nah nah no alleviating the pressure I
think I think that's gonna push him to a
level that he's never been before I know
I he's he's working his ass off I don't
know if you talked to him but he's
literally locked away in Big Bear he's
secluded he's isolated no friends no
family just his training camp four hours
a day in like I forget what's the
elevation they're like ten thousand feet
the point is it makes everything a
hundred times harder so yeah I want I
want him to feel the pressure because I
think it'll take him to a spot that he
needs to be to win this fight have you
been to any of his trainings not yet hey
let me tell you some Christmas break I
new years I was ready yeah yeah I'm
going up there his birthday is also
January 17th like like his commitment
and his ability to waive his desire to
party and celebrate his birthday
Christmas New Year's is unbelievable
I've never seen him as dedicated as he
is right now
when he's going through some personal
stuff he just split with Tanna have you
what do you make of that Oh
yeah you know must be so hard it must be
it must be so difficult for him I mean
talk about star-crossed lovers yeesh you
didn't believe this relationship to
begin with though right you were kind of
you're questioning it um yeah I mean
most people were I think you're his
brother it's true what you said is a
fact
hey hey what you want from me yeah we
want for me lady yeah they broke up
it's sad sort of I don't know I'm sure
they'll be all right yeah she's here
today she's co-hosting can we talk about
this what the what
why are you co-hosting maybe because I
lost I don't know I don't know that's
actually a great question what I you
know why I cuz I think I'm biased but
tan has tennis tennis bites too I mean
she was kind of married to the guy fake
married to the guy this is this is odd
yeah it's Jake's now ex-wife assuming
it's official is co-hosting a boxing
press conference this is odd I don't
know his boxing press conference my head
hurts
it's oh yeah do not do not do it for the
cloud they're in love he said they're
not in love anymore that's what I just
said do not in love anymore are you at
your friends with Tana I loved Hannah I
loved it I I will still consider Tana a
sister oh yeah
in law no just start up sister she's
like Isis she looks she's blonde she
looks like us as far as I know she could
be my sister
when are you gonna get back in the ring
because I saw was it Twitter Instagram
maybe you want to take on Antonio Brown
is that a thing that's happening I would
love to take on Antonia Brown I don't
know if an Antonio Brown wants to take
on me I am I am hesitant because I'm not
sure how serious he thinks I am I'm not
I I think I think he may be all talk
but you're dead serious you would do
this I would absolutely do this I think
I think you'd be the biggest fight of
2020 to be on I think it might be the
biggest event of 2020 if it happened
like bigger than McGregor's return
bigger than wilder fury and Sonia Brown
for slogan Paul would be the biggest
amount of 2020 yeah is there anyone else
you want to fight anyone else on that
list where you just wanna call him out
no I got I got I mean I had a list and
Tony Brown seemed like the perfect
candidate candidate for me um have you
met him before I have I have we actually
hung out I think I think like four years
ago at the Super Bowl I went through his
house and and yeah we got along but at
the same time like you know he's out of
shaky fast I've had a shaky pass too I
think it'd be an entertaining fight I
think I think it merged mainstream and
digital in a way that hasn't been done
yet like think about it
ksi for slogan Paul - it's me fighting
like a British youtuber who by the way
if you're not in the UK you don't know
who this guy is
Antonio Brown is a is that Antonio Brown
is a mainstream athletic icon and I've
managed to become a household name
through you know mistakes wins whatever
whatever it is I think I think this
could really really really break some
boundaries you have been through a lot
what does 2020 look like for you so far
so what's on the agenda what do you have
coming up come on yes in a decade this
in the decade uh I feel I feel really
good I feel really optimistic through
through discipline I've been saying this
dude disciplined creativity and routine
that's when my takeover is gonna happen
once again like 2017 was one of the
biggest years of my life and I think I
can make that happen again if we're just
smart strategic with what we do you know
with whether it's between fights content
I mean I'm not become a tick-tock God
tick tocks popping off right now you who
knows who knows but um yeah just overall
like overall overall extremely
optimistic and hopeful and before I let
you go I know you're friends with Justin
Bieber he actually walked out when you
did your fight it's reported that he has
Lyme disease I saw this probably three
minutes ago I just saw on his Instagram
like I just commented yeah the attacks
did you call you know I literally just
found out in it and I will I mean I
commented on his Instagram post I said
adapt and overcome like nothing in stop
to stop the king and it's true like he's
just been through so much like beaver
beaver knows how to adapt and overcome
and it looks like he has to be honest
like he said he had been struggling with
it and hopefully he's he's doing much
better than he was but my head Lyme
disease that is that is that is not a
joke of an illness it's definitely it's
definitely something it'll take a an
effect on your mental physical
everything so yeah if there's anyone
that can that can that can beat it it's
it's Bieber your guys's friendship too
it's unexpected but it's solid it is it
is solid and uh yeah I think I think
just blessed Justin you still gotta send
me some drew looking forward to guys
around here wearing the drew house shirt
that's not a bunch of them yeah on
Jake's team yeah but yeah you know
hopefully hopefully if I fight a B he'll
walk out with me then too but we'll see
yeah he's a friend he's cool before I
let you go are both Paul brothers single
now are you dating anyone uh Internet
always wants to know yeah yeah no I'm
single I'm single right now I will say
though I think 2020 is a year of the
girlfriend
I'm confident settle down I think so wow
this is a big moment yeah yeah yeah
we'll see up I'm probably really wrong
but ha ha ha ho nice well what are you
looking for for all the viewers out
there I'll tell you who I'm I admit a
list these are these are qualities I
look for in in a girlfriend he's lying
no I swear to God oh yeah girlfriend it
really is a little girlfriend qualities
when do you oddest 21st 2019 which was
in my training camp you know a training
camp you have a lot of time to do
nothing all right so this is for my
future wife just like try to check as
many of these boxes as you can
girlfriend qualities wit confidence
intelligence opinionated empathetic
self-aware active listener sexual
deviant she got me a sexual deviant tell
me you don't want your wife to be fdv
come on guy
talented worldly she's gotta have
foresight and she got to be insightful
well here's to hoping yeah here's to
hope when you find love and happiness in
2020 and also let your brother win thank
you thank you so much
[Music]